selon les experts
lorsque quelqu'un veut changer de
carrière les premières étapes sont un de
faire un bilan de ses compétences et de
deux de renouer avec ses rêves
d'ici quelques années des systèmes et
des parents vous proposer des parcours
d'apprentissage des médecines que
pourriez faire basé sur vos compétences
antérieures sur vos intérêts sur vos
passions mais aussi sur la
reconnaissance de vos applications ou de
vos accomplissements plus que ça c'est
plate forme leur vont vous proposer des
parcours de formation à travers
plusieurs organisations vont vous donner
un accès à une liste d'entreprises qui
pourraient vous embaucher et à quel
niveau salarial parce que changer de
carrière on va tous y passer et
plusieurs fois mais aujourd'hui encore
c'est à l'école dans les bancs
d'université ou académique que l'on
apprend des métiers qu'on vaut rien on
va faire pour plusieurs années avec
l'accélération des technologies et le
partage des innovations plusieurs
métiers on nous annonce souvent vont
disparaître mais la vaste majorité des
métiers des compétences vont être à
modifier très rapidement les finissants
qui sortent des écoles ne sont pas
réellement prêts à commencer un travail
immédiatement
on aperçoit l'écart de qualification ou
le ski le gap en angle on est à une
époque où les jeunes doivent rapidement
s'adapter à de nouvelles formations à
des nouveaux contextes d'apprentissage
et c'est un défi majeur de nos sociétés
on parle aussi des compétences du 21e
siècle
1 les savoir-être les savent ce qu'ils
comme la communication la collaboration
où la créativité sont assez difficiles à
valider pourtant très recherchée par les
entreprises et les recruteurs
aujourd'hui une vision de
l'apprentissage tout au long de la vie
s'expriment à travers des nouvelles
manières d'enseigner ou d'apprendre par
exemple pédagogie par projets mais aussi
à travers des nouveaux lieux
d'apprentissage
on parle de la formation en ligne sur
internet comme les boucs
on parle aussi dans les bibliothèques
dans les lieux culturels mais aussi dans
les ateliers de fabrication numérique
les fables on est face à un défi majeur
de passer à un modèle de développement
des compétences de la reconnaissance de
l'expérience et les accomplissements
mais imagine le défi de documenter de
valider les compétences de tous à
travers des contextes multiples et très
différents mais justement aujourd'hui
c'est encore le diplôme kirwa la manière
de valoriser de et de représenter un
apprentissage passe encore par des
systèmes d'évaluation basé sur des notes
qu'on obtient lors d'examens ou de test
alors que avoir un bep plus où 85% sur
un diplôme ne nous permet pas de bien
comprendre ce que la personne a appris à
développer et surtout ce qui l a eu
comme apprentissage de compétences
concrètes et aussi le modèle actuel
force le succès de tous au même moment
alors qu'on sait très bien que les
personnes apprennent à des rythmes très
différents donc l'enjeu est très grands
aussi lorsque l'on doit rédiger nos
propres cva lorsqu'on cherche un emploi
c'est nous-mêmes qui allons rédiger
notre cv ou créé un profil sur les
réseaux sociaux comme sur linkedin et
cet enjeu d'avoir présenté qui ont ni
comment on peut contribuer à une
organisation et un défi actuellement
très important donc il devient
nécessaire de numériser et de valider
les compétences et les diplômes de façon
efficace comme chercheurs et
entrepreneurs depuis plusieurs années
j'explore une belle façon de pouvoir
innover en termes de pédagogie et de
représentation de l'apprentissage
donc il existe actuellement on aperçoit
les badges amérique donc des systèmes de
micro certification un peu comme dans le
monde des scouts où dans le monde des
jeux vidéo ceux qui sont adeptes
on progresse à travers des étapes et des
parcours d'apprentissage
ces micro certification là permettent de
générer des diplômés numérisés le
concept est né en 2011 au 2 juillet avec
la fondation mozilla
donc concrètement au niveau technique
badge
une page web unique comme on voit ici
qui conseille les informations complètes
autour d'une compétence donc les
méthodes données sont encodées pour
représenter une compétence ou un
accomplissement les badges peuvent être
aussi dans un standard open badge ce qui
permet de pour le futur de prendre un
badge de le transporter dans un autre
plateforme d'évaluation et de
reconnaissance
lorsqu'on obtient un badge on peut il
est sécurisé et ont pu le déposer dans
un portfolio qui sur un site web
et lorsqu'on a mis en place notre
portfolio on peut facilement gérer les
diplômes ou les badges et aussi les
partager à travers les médias sociaux et
en ligne ou sur des sites web
l'apprentissage travers les pages
numériques peut être à la fois formelle
non formelle et informelle toutes les
raisons peuvent créer et gérer des
badges et les octroyer et la valeur des
badges vient vraiment de ce qu'ils
octroient de leur réputation mais aussi
du parcours pédagogique et du contenu
pédagogique que celui ci représente donc
les badges suis vraiment un outil très
puissant et dans mes recherches
académiques et dans ma pratique on est
vraiment grand troyes grand usage on
parle de vraiment un outil pour évaluer
bien sûr communiqué et structuré le
prince âgé et compétences il ya une
révolution qui peut être mise en place à
travers les badges pour l'évaluation
parce qu'on peut maintenant motivé la
l'apprentissage on peut reconnaître
l'effort le parcours et certifie bien
sûr et documenter les compétences
concrètes déjà quelques exemples
l'association cap 21 au québec offre de
la formation en développement
professionnel des enseignants à travers
bien sûr des formations à distance et
reconnu par des badges du numérique
ils songent ils sont classés par type de
contenus pédagogiques et par niveau de
difficulté notre exemple dans la même
veine c'est microsoft qui certifie les
incidents qui sont innovateurs dans leur
approche pédagogique à travers des
badges numérique on voit un exemple ici
ou un instru un enseignant peut utiliser
la plateforme où le jeu vidéo
minecraft et est reconnu comme étant
capable de l'utiliser dans un contexte
pédagogique
ou dans les universités on parle de
wichita state ici aux etats-unis qui ont
mis en place un système de badges pour
pouvoir reconnaître leurs programmes et
leurs compétences qui sont développés
qui sont directement liés avec le marché
du travail dans leur région donc près
d'un pont avec le monde du travail et le
monde a quitté d'un monde d'entreprise
quelques dizaines d'entreprises
utilisent des systèmes de base depuis
quelques années ibm et en inde et plus
précurseurs et ils ont actuellement mis
en place des systèmes de base pour
pouvoir travailler lors du recrutement
du développement professionnel et aussi
de la rétention de leurs employés
actuellement ils en ont plus de 1700
badges ou certifications différentes à
travers leur entreprise leur entreprise
et ils en ont décerné plus de 600 milles
à leurs employés et ce en même pas trois
ans
autre exemple l'association world chef
qui veut mettre en place une système de
reconnaissance des parcours
professionnels dans le monde de la
cuisine dont des grands cuisiniers
ils ont fait un des badges du parcours
de simple cuisine professionnelle à un
grand chef qui est aussi instructeur et
un lieu très intéressant pour
reconnaître l'apprentissage à travers
les badges mairie que ça fait partie de
mes intérêts au niveau de la recherche
que je fais au niveau du doctorat c'est
de reconnaître la protégeant contexte
non formelle comme dans un espace un
fable habib sy qui de san diego en
californie qui à travers ce barrage
reconnaît un parcours d'apprentissage
qui contient un ensemble de d'activités
de développement de connaissances de
rencontres avec des professionnels donc
vraiment de rendre l'activité
pédagogique très active
on est confronté aujourd'hui à un
environnement et à l'apprentissage qui
héberge beaucoup encore en silo le monde
académique n'est pas toujours en
harmonie avec le monde du travail entend
jamais parler un peu de l'écart de
qualification et c'est cette
structuration l'un des parcours
d'apprentissage dans ces nouveaux
écosystèmes d'après sage que nous
devrons travailler et les badges peuvent
contribuer à créer ce langage commun 7
cette vision disons plus structuré et
concrète de l'école vers le monde ce
travail est bien sûr dans mon travail on
va aussi être beaucoup en mode
d'apprentissage continu
bien entendu dans le futur
mais le grand défi de tout ce pourquoi
on ferait tout ça pour que les gens
puissent avoir un rôle à avoir un sens
de pouvoir retourner travailler d'avoir
une signification dans le monde du
travail
la prochaine frontière de l'humanité
c'est d'aller vivre sur une autre
planète
effectivement il en masse et space x et
beaucoup d'autres raids aller sur mars
pour pouvoir colonisés et surtout
devenir une espèce multimonétaire mais
imaginez ce qu'on devra inventer pour
être capable d'aller vivre sur une autre
planète
donc on va devoir inventer des systèmes
pour créer des d habitat durable de
l'énergie de la nourriture de l'eau
l'hygiène main à certains endroits mais
aussi apprendre à vivre ensemble mais on
va surtout se rendre compte rendu sur
mars que notre planète la terre est
vraiment un lieu qui est fragile qui est
le nôtre et qu'on doit s'occuper de
façon de prioritaire donc tout ce qu'on
va prototype est ici sur terre pour
pouvoir aller dans l'espace
ça va aussi potentiellement nous
permettre de sauver la planète en guinée
ou dans tout le moins de la rendre plus
acceptable pour la détruire comme on
fait actuellement
mais vous remarquerez que il ya beaucoup
d'innovations qui sont déjà en train de
se faire ici on parle de votre autonome
électrique on parle de l'intelligence
artificielle
on part décrypte oman et en parle d'un
nouveau système pour pouvoir produire de
façon beaucoup plus efficace la première
production robotisée bien sûr des
emplois vont disparaître mais ce qui va
voir baisser des nouveaux métiers et des
nouveau rôle à jouer dans cet écosystème
là et de l'eau les badges peuvent
contribuer mais j'ai beau de finir en
vous disant que pour aller dans l'espace
on a des compétences incroyable à
développer et à prototyper ici sur terre
donc c'est pour ça que les badges pour
moi sont un outil qui nous permettrait
d'aller dans l'espace et je pense qu'on
peut être comme moi mais aimeriez-vous
soit changer de carrière
merci
on le reçoit
j'ai un problème je travaille que des
gens fantastiques comme toi les
bénévoles
depuis quelques années les coachs ils
font un travail extraordinaire
je pense qu'ils apprennent beaucoup
aussi à travailler en équipe
mais il reste pas grand chose de cette
expérience la super pino soupe preuve
puis non je vais parler un petit peu
avec toi puis je me suis posé des
questions sli badge pouvait nous aider à
les optimiser un petit peu qu'est-ce
qu'on a passé ensemble puis à ce que les
badges peuvent aider finalement souligné
travail de ces gens là
bien sûr chaque conférencier ou acteurs
de l'événement on reçoit un diplôme à la
fin un papier avec une signature du
président et la collaboratrice et de
l'équipe qui est très bien c'est une
reconnaissance papier je pourrais
l'affiché sur mon mur mais l'utilisation
des badges amérique vient justement
kambly 7,7 et carl de pouvoir numériser
les compétences mais surtout dans ce cas
aussi reconnaître l'effort est ce que
les gens ont accompli pour que les
événements aujourd'hui et lieux et tous
les rôles donc on a créé des badges
ensemble pour pouvoir les voiles et
comment ils soient moins de pouvoir
émettre des badges à tous les bénévoles
qui ont travaillé très fort à
l'événement bien sûr au coach qui ont
accompagné chaque conférencier au
conférencier eux mêmes et aussi au chef
d'équipé à la coordination de
l'événement
donc les bases seront remis
prochainement à tous les acteurs de cet
événement là et pour les années à suivre
oui oui centenaire
n'est ce pas un petit coup est injuste
parce que ça fait trois ans que je fais
ce métier première année il avait aussi
des conférences extraordinaire il y
avait aussi des coachs
alors c'est malheureusement il y aurait
dû avoir des badges à l'époque mais non
c'est pas vrai une des forces aussi
débattre c'est que ces rétroactif
ibm vraiment fait ils ont beaucoup de
batteries parce qu'ils ont
rétroactivement certifié par badge des
compétences et des diplômes qui ont été
offertes donc l'ensemble de tes trois
années d qui pond pouvoir être reconnues
pour leurs efforts et même rajouté la
valeur pour ceux qui ont beaucoup de
like sur le web
enfin de ses os 6 donc de temps d'y
remédier les conférenciers de la
première année la deuxième année les
comptes et les bénévoles vont tous
pouvoir avoir des badges rétroactivement
de reconnaissance oui yes
[Applaudissements]
lancée et baggio ont-elles une espérance
de vie c'est dessus oui tout à fait en
fait dans concret des badges et qu'on
les octrois dans le causse avec
l'organisme cap 3d batch pour le tedx
laval
c'est vous qui allez garantir la
viabilité du badge et on peut avoir une
durée de vie dans ce que si c'est des
badges à vie parce qu'on a accompli
quelque chose mais les badges peuvent
aussi avoir une durée en deux temps
limité selon quand c'est de
l'information par exemple en entreprise
etc
mais dans ce que s'ils ont levé qu'une
tous en nous sommes transformés par ses
expériences donc nous sommes marqués
pour toujours
un dernier point aux hypothèques sur
lies hebbadj on n'arrête pas sa tête ex
laval tout à fait qu'est ce qu'on fait
ouais moi oui on prend la voiture et on
va baston essayer de proposer des
systèmes de badges pour tout l'été dicks
à travers le monde ouais mais sa porte
de la rage merci beaucoup je bois merci
ça pousse